hola raúl es una visita expresa de dos
días por dubai qatar y por arabia
saudita básicamente la lucha contra el
terrorismo raúl uno de los temas
principales a tratar con estos países
también la estabilidad de la región y
los acuerdos comerciales y en ese
sentido el presidente manuel macrón raúl
ya ha conseguido un gran logro esta
mañana firmando un acuerdo millonario
con
justamente dubai por la compra de 80
aviones de combate rafale 12
helicópteros
caracas un contrato millonario raúl de
17.000 millones de euros los primeros
aviones van a ser entregados en el año
2027 el presidente estaba muy contento y
toda francia también son de la empresa
los aviones gasol a empieza francesa y
los helicópteros de airbús es un
contrato que ha tomado 13 años tres
presidentes han estado negociando este
acuerdo con los emiratos y es porque
también este tipo de compras no son sólo
económicas sino que también políticas
raúl siguiente manuel macrón dice que
esto es una manera de concretizar una
alianza estratégica con dubai de hecho
francia tiene tres bases militares allá
una aérea dos puertos y una base
terrestre y eso le sirve también a
francia para realizar misiones hacia
otros lugares concretamente lindo
pacífico todos dicen que este contrato
raúl es la revancha de lo que no se
firmó con australia y recuerde ustedes
ese contrato sobre los submarinos sin
embargo la visita el presidente manual
macrón también es criticada por las ongs
de derechos humanos ya que muchas de
estas armas que vende francia a los
países del golfo pérsico se sabe son
utilizadas en el conflicto en yemen
donde arabia saudita y sus aliados están
acusados de crímenes contra la humanidad
y también esta visita es criticada raúl
porque el presidente emmanuel macrón en
arabia saudita se va a reunir con el
príncipe heredero que recordemos está
acusado por la muerte de jamal cayó y el
periodista saudí que murió recordemos en
turquía asesinado por cierto